on m'avait dit mais voilà donc on a le
bec moi je m'en sors assez bien la dame
ans très bien et la lazio 18 de moyenne
on peut tous l'applaudir ouais bravo
je savais que j'allais avoir mon bac
mais je savais pas quelle mention je
pensais que j'allais avoir la mention
bien mais du coup j'ai été surpris qu'il
joue très bien où je contente admis
mention très bien au bac assez spécial
pas qu'ils demandaient pas trop
d'efforts qui demandait de l'effort sur
l'annexé terme et de l'effort sur une
courte période et déçu quand les
week-ends de l'excision xt restore moi
j'ai mon bac sans mention j'étais pas
mal de la mention mais voilà avec 10 80
ch plutôt content quand même de la voir
avec le co vide c'est vrai qu'on
appréhendait beaucoup comment allaient
être les bulletins comment ça allait se
passer donc
on hésite est certain qu'on est étroit
de notre classe a est passé à la limite
donc on savait pas trop ce qu'on avait
passé en rattrapage ou pas